and
[Music]
you're you've got someone new
what obligation
does the new man have now to your child
from another
man
would you like like what like does he
take on all of the responsibility as a
father
or is there some kind of halfway
dad situation going on
does that make sense because a lot of
women
have
expect a man for instance there was a
viral video this week you know a couple
of days ago where this woman
was she had a father of her child she
had three other children and he came to
bring his child every day lunch and then
she was like oh i've got three other
kids and he's like those ain't my kids
i've got one with you i don't have an
obligation to look after your children
so i'm just like do women who already
have children think that their new man
or another man has the obligation to
look after the children that aren't his
i think it depends on if you're dating
or if you're or if you're taking things
serious i think it depends if you're
dating they don't need to see your child
you're just you know dating and doing
your thing but if you are building with
you you're moving on and you're building
with that person you're gonna you know
get engaged get married have children
and stuff it that kind of comes with
that kind of you you kind of see how
they build their own relationship as
well i feel i feel like you do group
stuff you go out to eat you do whatever
you need to do you know and you see if
that when you're doing introducing after
six months or after a year you see if
your child how they are with that person
you need to see if they if they've got
that relationship you can't force you
can't force it
is he allowed to discipline your child
um
it depends on that situation this is the
thing because because
yeah
i was in a relationship for like 10
years right and when i was in that
relationship i was with a woman who
already had a child
we had a child together but what was
very um
very apparent to me within that
relationship was that i was not allowed
to discipline this child the way i could
discipline my own child right because
the child still had the father in their
life the father would have something to
say about it if i disciplined the child
in a certain way and so
i
there's a lot of men out here saying
that they wouldn't get with a woman a
lot of men saying they wouldn't get with
a woman who already has a child because
you get a lot of the benefits
sorry you don't get all of the benefits
of being a father
right but you have the responsibility as
a father so it's like
what is the incentive for men
to actually get with women who actually
already have children when you know that
at some point in time you are going to
be reminded that that child ain't yours
i'm going to be controversial and say i
think the father should
look after the kid
they're better off statistically yeah
kids are better off after the age of
like eight with their fathers over their
mothers especially even financially like
single fathers tend to be better with
money than single mothers oh wait no i'm
talking about my i i think the step dad
should look after the
the step kid oh the steps that okay
the reason why i say this is because
you're picking the woman
you know she's got a kid already so you
you should assume that you're going to
have to look after her kid even though
she might not want you to that's it's
like you're picking the woman not the
child no but you know she's got a child
so you're picking the woman and the
child if it's not
she's not gonna step she's not gonna
like um put the kid up for adoption like
just like no you know they're coming as
a pair so you gotta prepare yourself
already to be like you know what i might
not be able to discipline him the way
that i want to i'm sorry i know i'm
gonna have to pay for his this i'm gonna
have to pay for that i'm gonna have to
pay for that i know i'm gonna have to
get this in my air about how you talking
to him please talk to me instead of
talking to the kid and i know you're
gonna get that but i think i think that
um step dads should be allowed to
discipline the kids because yeah because
like that it's what he's signing up for
if he's going to take on the
responsibility he should get
it but might as well allow you to do it
though
that's not your child that's my child
i'll discipline the child yeah they're
nine times out of ten that's what
mothers will do
is they disagree though the door's there
no i think
if it's not natural it's not organic you
can't fool someone into obligation if
you do that it builds resentment and
that's like coercive control that's like
mental abuse and women complain about
that all the time and what i notice as
well with the women i know that's like
that they're um usually hypocritical
it's double standards they they can do
that kind of pair and said oh well he's
not my child if the father has one
already but if we do that it's a big
problem
this is where this is what i just
disagree with yeah that's what but
that's why men like oftentimes don't get
involved with single moms because it's
just it's too confusing for them i'm
allowed to do this but not that and i'm
taking on the responsibility but i don't
get any of the authority
and that's why a lot of times they come
out and say it's a bad deal and you know
what that does for children
children even if you've got like two
children one's yours and one's not yours
that other child sees
that that child gets treated differently
right and so
that child one of the children know that
if they're left with stepdad they can
probably get away with a little bit more
than they could if it was actual dead do
you know what i mean and so they'll push
the boundaries listen up trust me i've
been there yeah i've been there like
they will push the boundaries that
because they know you can't discipline
me like my mom can disagree or my dad
can discipline me
you say that you say that in my
experience obviously i'm not saying this
for everybody but in my experience my
first mother
herodis favored me
at one point he drew me in place of his
dad in his primary school book and all
because i gave him routine and structure
i wasn't too pally pally with him i said
look this is the boundaries you're
stressing out your mother you've got a
certain bedtime you have to go to bed
you said you need to help her out
because i said a lot of the time she's
running around and you're capable
he could die in his clothes he's good at
folding so i said you need to give him a
bit more responsibility and what i found
amazing at the time i thought he
despised me but he actually started we
started to get really get on and in a
second
i think because he's dead one actually
around
he favored me as well so that that
middle one actually handed me better
than my own son but you know that's what
a lot of people see that they will see
that and they'll say that as a bad thing
not knowing that you're actually helping
the you
so to be fair he's mother she actually
liked it she encouraged it which i found
was a bit peculiar so she was he the
first one
so we're talking about like women that
don't want their partner to discipline
the kid
so like even when he's like being a man
in the house and being like
pick up that and whatever like she might
not like it but he might like it like
when i grew up with a stepdad my mom
wouldn't know like certain times like
you know what i mean i'd be like raw
like now i'm looking back i'm like
this man is amazing bro like do you know
what i mean like he took me on as a
stepson and
treated me like all his other children
and did you push the boundaries of him
knowing that was you was your actual
biological dad around
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a bit of a
rich dad poor dad like so basically i
was brought up in trinidad and england
and trinidad than england right my dad
was here my stepdad was in trinidad
right with my mom
and
he was muslim
so i was on the
militant
is style you know i'm saying without the
i without the terrorism part but you
know what i'm trying to say like five
times a day like ramadan everything
ready but i'm saying when i look back at
that now that was disciplined
do you know what i mean i wouldn't see
as that i would be like right this
prayer is so annoying like who do you
think he is my dad do you think my dad
do you think times have changed now
though
like do you think times have changed
like children do you think children show
step
fathers and mothers
adults in general the same respect that
they did when you were growing up it
depends on who's the parent yeah it
depends and the character of the child
as well